when something is this it is in the
human Spirit to go here when the answer
to solve it is to go here parenting did
this because we were parented like this
and so we went here yes and so we try to
find this and that's really hard because
the world is actually doing this I think
that the world is infatuated with being
either blue or red and I think all of
the answers are being purple this is a
tough sentence to say but I really
believe that parenting over the last 25
years has has lost its way and it's too
bad cuz I think it's come from a very
well-intended framework eighth place
trophies they were well- intended we
didn't want to make people feel bad if
they weren't good at sports but it led
to us eliminating Merit which is very
important and more importantly it led us
to a very scary place which is people
fear losing I don't know if you heard
but life is predominantly losing with
occasional micro wins that's why this is
important to me and most things are
important to me but I think a lot of it
is where parenting is